j'aimerais demander un pardon ce soir à
joly j'aimerais demander pardon
voilà à tous les gens que j'ai pu
blesser parfois voilà c'est vrai que
parfois lachor des vans à une vanne qui
peut partir qui peut partir comme ça qui
peut que je pense pas vraiment je
voudrais demander pardon aussi parfois
aux personnes de voilà aux gens que
c'est me voilà à la régie quand je les
bouscule un peu parce qu'ils font un
travail incroyable à tous les gens qui
sont autour
je devrais demander pardon aussi au
public parfois parce que quand ils
viennent dans mes émissions à l'ail ils
peuvent repartir un peu tâche et ce ne
sera pas le cas je voudrais demander
pardon aussi à tous les mecs que j'ai un
peu critique et voilà j'ai été un petit
peu loin tient parfois donc ce soir
c'est vrai que parfois j'ai trouvé que
j'étais un petit peu dur parfois
géraldine oui parce que vous dites que
vous pensez voilà c'est sa voix âpre et
parfois on peut le regretter
oui donc c'est vrai que j'ai plus
regretté voilà parce que c'est parfois
je suis allé trop loin
voilà j'ai été souvent sans filtre je
voudrais demander pardon siam amis
parfois parce que ses vrais amis
voilà exactement déjà voilà de l'appeler
mamie parce que je sais que elle et elle
est pas mal du tout dans sa tête elle
est plus à l'état les jeunes ont fait un
bien sûr voilà mais c'est vrai et je
sais que mamie vous n'aimez pas que je
vous la pelle manille donc ce soir je
vous appellerai à partir de ce soir je
vous appellerai plus manu mais mais mais
[Musique]
je vais demander pardon à benjamin
castaldi
donc pourquoi de deux parfois m'énerver
ce que vous cherchez parfois je joue je
peux vous vous tapez mais gentiment gens
s'en vont
j'aurais demandé pardon donc à mon goût
de christophe carrière parce que ça fait
longtemps que je n'ai pas mis dans
l'émission voilà je suis très heureux de
le retrouver
voilà pardon je t'avais pas oublié mais
bon voilà demandé pardon à kelly aussi
parce que parfois je les engueule c'est
vrai parce que voilà comme celle sa part
comme ça pardon à françois view
en fait non pardonne parlons à
jean-michel moshiri parce que c'est vrai
que parfois c'est vrai que je t'appelle
plus souvent pour les mauvaises choses
que pour les bonnes mais tu sais que je
te trouve excellent et que tu es
vraiment mon ami pour toujours je le
sais voilà tu sais voilà je ne
demanderai pas pardon aux ménages pardon
et eric naulleau de l'avoir embarqué
dans cette galère alors qu'il était
tranquillement
oui j'espère que tu es heureux quand
même ferai mon bouder on voit ravir pas
de pardon entrerait c'est vrai géraldine
pardon aussi voilà de de t'avoir sortie
de ton confort c'est vrai et je vais me
demander pardon surtout pour un truc
c'est pour le chocolat
c
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas mal
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]